Hello, everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome back to SCP Containment Breach.
Now we're going down this elevator...
...it may or may not be the right place that I need to go, but I know... I know what awaits me.
The fuck is that? Oh. Oh yeah, that's right. Okay, so I completely remember. These things down here are blind.
They can't actually see me, but they can smell me and they can hear me.
Okay, that's just smoke, don't need to worry about that.
HEEEYYY
Don't mind me...
I don't like music down here, but it okay. Everything's fine.
Don't worry about it! Um.. *gasp*
Hi, whoa, hi...
He, he, he, he, he, heee
ha ha ha ha... hi.
You're a cutie. Oh, boy, they're gonna kill me. Oh, cutie's gonna kill me.
Oh no. Okay. It's fine. Oh boy
He he... alright.
Okay...
All right, so, they patrol this downstairs area,
And I don't think it's going to be as easy as walking down here because I think they're going to loop. Ugh. I don't quite remember
Oh, I don't quite remember!
What is... I don't know what that is. What is that? Oh, it's night vision. Oh, that'd be a smart idea!
Ooohhhhh
Hiii~~!
Hii.
Hidey hidey uh ahh ahh
ahh ahh ah AH AHH! I don't think it sees me, but I need to move!
[Creature: Who the hell is that?]
NOONE!
I forgot that they had human voices!
... uh... uh... HUHH
They can mimic. They can mimic. They can mimic people, I forgot about that!
Okay, all right. You're fine. You just skedaddle on by, I'll be here... proceeding to...
*absolute silence*
Hi.
How are you?
You good?
Ooh. Hi.
Okay. So he - it - she - they - if - that thing...
They just need to -
[Creature: Is someone there?]
... loop on by and that's totally fine. They -
- this SCP is particularly scary cuz they mimic the things
That they hear and I I don't know if it's by some psychic connection, but it's meant to lure
Whatever creature it is, and um...
[Creature: Hello?]
and I don't know if they're intelligent to the point where they could
actually know that it's people calling out to them
so I don't think that's it.
It's gonna make another loop and I should be okay.
unless it decides to turn around and that'd be cool too, I guess
Yeah, I don't think it has any other intelligence besides. Just mimicry so the objective here is to go through this...
...place to try to find the other-
the other- haaah
*manly screams*
Oh God, no, I'm out of breath. Oh God, oh God, oh God, oh God, oh God. Ohhhh fuck me. Okay, alright
I guess I- *incoherent babbling*
I don't know why it didn't go for me right then and there. I don't know why.
I don't know why, I think it's gonna come down this way
Yep, it's gonna come down this way, okay, so I just need to sneak
[Creature: Hey, who's there?]
Noone...
[Creature: Oh god, what the hell is that!?]
Ugh. Yeah, it mimics the last thing that the uh...
*screaming*
OHGOD
Oh God, oh put on the-fricken-the gas- whoaaaaaah
*markiplier sounds*
Why are we... why are we not... why are we not moving? Why are we not moving?
Am I moving? Ohhh...
There we go
okay, all right, okay, all right, so
'Where are we?' is the big question. So we...
wut? wuut?
What is this? I've never seen this before? There's blood there, but I don't know if that's oh
HEY, fucking. God damn it. Hi, you sack of shit, okay, so...
I've never actually seen this before so there's gonna be a new experience for me
If I'm ready for it. I didn't know this was just like here you know [oh]
Femme fatale [oh]
I don't want to look at him. Whatever [it] is. I want to look at it until I say
All right, we saved now we can die a horrible horrible death
What are you?
I
Don't know this one. I really really [don't] know this one
There's no button here not that [I] would want to go in there anyway. Oh
You have a friend
Don't fucking help hey oh, oh, oh
Oh, it's open now. [oh]
I don't know what this is is the word shadow puppet show in the world. Oh
I
Don't like all hey hey, hi, okay alrighty, then
oh HEY!
OW!! OWIE!
Okay, that's my spine. Yeah, that's my point. I need that all right there goes my brain
It's not okay
fucking hell
What oh look oh?
and [see] p2o5 cycle seems to have resumed its normal course after the anomalies observed during redacted the body of Subject P9 3
[4] [1] was discovered inside the chamber
the subject exhibits signs of blunt Force Trauma typical for personnel who entered the chamber when the lights are
off
Okay
[that] didn't go [very] well for me
Let me actually read [what] this says there's something strange going on here the cycle seems to have sped up
Significantly one of the horn figures has already appeared in it's currently having dinner with her
So who is she there's no NCP documentation to go along with this so it's kind of just like
Let me just see if I [can] watch the full cycle
you know
from here
Because I don't know what this is all about like I left it
It's Scp 205 in case you want to read up on it on your own, but I've never ever
Seen this before in my life
Stop that. Can I just enjoy the goddamn show here because I'm go hi. I guess you're going to be there by suppose
Okay, so there's a horn figure and then the door opens, and I ain't going to go in the room
Ain't [Gonna] go in the room [well] the doors not open anymore, so I guess my opportunity has gone
hi, oh
Oh and another member [of] the party oh
I
Don't like this. Oh, I don't like this and I want to I want to go or leave, okay?
So I'm gonna just guess that if I go in there again
It's going to be nothing but death and I'm not gonna be privy to that can I okay all right?
So you all have fun. They're
Doing whatever that is oh
Was a new oh, that's new oh, oh
Did you just punch her now? That's just spelling out my fate of what's Gonna happen to me
If I go down there, but the bad thing is now, I don't have a way to go back. Oh
Boy, oh, well, you know I'm just gonna lock [that] in there. Let's forget about that
I'm gonna go back down because the only way I can go is back down
Who's no point?
The only thing on the [other] side of this was another Svp and frankly. I'm not happy I went down there
Huh, I'm not happy. I saw amy go back
Flip you dippy dude okay here. We go back into the mist of [hell]. So there was other branching paths down here
Oh else is going I've never seen the rest of this mmM
They're not oh
Whole section can you pump it? Why why why why why didn't that work yeah?
Fighting you're right there. Why don't you work? Oh?
Like that [oh] the storage area [stall] oh, yeah, you are
our start
It's just somebody else oh
Why are you just?
Why are you just in I thought? I lost you for a moment there. Oh
There [you] are
I
Just got to get back now
Huh, I think I might be able to Sprint through there with just my gas mask
I
Don't [know] where it is. [oh] no worries, [okay]? [I] can I don't need that
What is this? What is that? There's nothing? What is that there? Oh?
Okay, I think we are fine. [I] think we are fine
Okay
[all] right, we did it [whoa]
[oh]
I don't feel good about that. I don't feel good about this at all, okay
But either way, we made it down into the elevator of hell, and we're back up
So we still need to find where the door control is I?
Think now it must be in one of the unexplored areas that I was in I
was in like the other containment areas, so
I'm gonna find that in the next episode. I'm all out of time for this one
So thank you everybody so much for watching and as always I will see you in the next video. Bye